Lo que queremos hacer en este video es pensar
en cuánto es 8 + 6, y para ayudarnos tenemos 8
bloques que se muestran aquí, y tenemos otros 6
bloques que se muestran en color rosa. Pausen el
video y traten de resolverlo. Hay muchas formas de
abordarlo, pero la forma en que me gusta hacerlo
es ver si podemos formar un grupo de 10 con
algunos de estos bloques y luego ver cuántos
quedan. De modo que si queremos hacer un grupo
de 10, usaremos estos 8: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
y luego necesitamos 2 más que podríamos conseguir
de estos 6 que tenemos aquí, y nos sobran: 1, 2,
3, 4. Y para apreciar cómo resulta eso, podemos
tomar los 8 y luego 2 de los 6 para hacer un
grupo de 10, los acomodé en una barra completa.
Así que sabemos que nuestra respuesta va a tener
una decena; esto nos dice que es una decena.
Y luego, ¿cuántas unidades nos quedan? Bueno,
aquí podemos ver que nos sobran 4, son 4
unidades. Si pensamos en el valor posicional,
esto es una decena y cuatro unidades o 14,
tenemos 10 y otros 4, que es lo mismo que 14.